notre série de portraits avoir 20 ans
dans les années 2020 avec le témoignage
d'elliot vous avez sans doute déjà
entendu parler de personnalités
transgenres sans forcément imaginer les
difficultés liées aux sentiments
profonds de rejet il a choisi de se
raconter dans un livre et a accepté de
se livrer à bamba guèye et anthony capra
pour faire évoluer les mentalités
c'est dur c'est dur
c'est dur d'avoir 20 en 2009 c'est
unique
[Musique]
bonjour tout le monde je m'appelle
elliott saxo j'ai 20 ans je vis à dijon
en côte d'or et je suis en transe
je suis né dans un corps de femme je
m'appelais milena c'est surtout au
collège que j'ai lu la remarque et
j'étais garçon manqué mais vraiment et
je faisais tout comme un garçon je
voulais rien à voir avec une fille au
niveau de ma famille qui eux et des
témoins de jéhovah eux ont été
totalement contre
mon même rogner
[Musique]
elle je lui ai quand même demandé
gentiment sa voulait reprendre le
contact et choisir mon prénom vu que
c'était ma mère est pareil après je n'ai
plus jamais de nouvelles d'elle là c'est
moi et mes cousines quand on avait 7 ans
voilà bon on reconnaît peut-être ne pas
du tout vu voilà ça c'était moi quand
j'avais 7 ans avec mes deux cousines
j'aurais vraiment pas pu continuer à
vivre dans le corps d'une femme vraiment
je pense que
si je n'avais pas entamer une transition
de genre la seule personne qui en sort
aurait pu me maintenir en vie ce mon
petit frère
j'ai voulu faire une transition seul
c'est horrible mais je me suis fait
importer illégalement de la testostérone
là où j'ai commencé à faire mes propres
injections mais seuls avec un dosage qui
ne convenait pas du tout après au bout
de deux des injections j'ai eu
énormément d'effets secondaires ce qui a
fait que j'ai préféré arrêter
j'ai commencé à faire la transition de
genre avec des endocrinologues des
psychiatres et actuellement je suis en
lien avec un chirurgien
alors personnellement on a la chance en
tant qu'homme transgenres c'est qu'on a
beaucoup d'effet positif c'est à dire
qu'on va avoir la voix qui mue la
pilosité qui augmente ainsi que la
répartition des graisses le seul
problème qu'on va avoir c'est qu'il va
falloir faire des opérations telles
qu'un mec tommy pour avoir un dans ce
plat
faut se dire qu'une transition c'est à
vie
j'ai voulu vraiment faire ce livre pour
expliquer à des personnes qui comme moi
ont ils tant de difficultés parce que
j'ai commencé une transition
j'étais très mal renseigné j'ai été très
mal suivis on m'a pas donné plus
d'explications que cela ce qui a fait
que j'ai fait énormément de recherches
qui m'a fait perdre beaucoup de temps et
je me suis dit si des personnes dans mon
cas avait ce livre ça serait bien plus
facile pour eux
avoir 20 ans en 2021 surtout quand lgbt
c'est on soit horrible comme ça peut
être génial
dans la vie de tous les jours j'ai
énormément de propos transphobes même d
un jour dans la rue en plein public
salue sa vas y toi
voilà bah ouais depuis après
il ya un certain âge et héros qui
accepte voilà notre différence et autres
mais y en a d'autres qui vont nous juger
ou soi-même sans même le vouloir ils
vont dire des propos parfois homophobes
ce qui nous rend mal à l'aise le
parcours des lieux signer il est beau et
j'ai hâte de lire son livre mois pour
connaître encore plus de choses qui a
traversé dans son camp ce moment quand
même qu'a été facile mais quand même
qu'il ya eu des moments difficiles et vu
que je le connais que depuis la pride
c'est vrai que j'aimerais bien pouvoir
me mettre à sa place en lisant son livre
on va vendre déjà j'aurai fini une
grande partie de ma transition voilà ce
qui va être est génial mais après ben il
ne sait pas où la vie nous mène dans
tous les cas mon qui fera sera majeur
alors je pense reprendre contact avec
lui
horaires attraper toutes ces années et
pourquoi pas rester avec mon compagnon
s'ils me supporter encore
[Musique]